this corner of north yorkshire used to
produce
so much electricity it was known as
megawatt valley
thousands of jobs were generated by
three power stations
until the lights went out at two of them
climate change triggered a push away
from coal to clean energy
britain's green transition was underway
richard wilson worked at the power
station at ferrybridge for nearly 40
years becoming
a senior manager until coal and his job
weren't needed anymore i am a casualty
of climate change because i've lost my
job because the power station that i
worked at
was by the government closed down and
their reason for that was
climate they were saving the world for
climate change it makes you think
well i've worked here for 38 years was
it worth it do you think enough was done
to help people like you keep jobs we
were in the front trenches and we
but we weren't being shot at from the
front we've been shut up from the back
thrown to the walls is a good way of
saying we don't want to go that way
the country's going this way and how
does that make you feel uh it did
make you feel angry and if you like
not not worth too much
the think tank the ippr estimates by the
end of the year
1.7 million jobs could go as a result of
the covet crisis
in the uk but data compiled exclusively
for sky news shows green jobs could help
plug this gap
with bold investment 1.6 million jobs
could be created in the next
decade
there were bold changes at the third of
the three north yorkshire power stations
tracks the only one that adapted and
survived
each of these huge biomass domes
contains
75 000 tons of wood pellets
a renewable energy source delivered by
train
which is now the backbone of the plant's
electricity production
this is just a fraction of the amount of
coal
that used to be stored here last year
just four percent of the electricity
generated at tracks
came from coal and by next summer
there'll be nothing left
cole will have been completely erased
from the landscape
jason shipstone has worked at drax for
more than 30 years
and now leads the piloting of carbon
capture technology
at the heart of draxi's ambition to be
carbon negative
by 2030 these transitions can be
difficult
tracks we've changed we have to change
we are in a climate emergency we do have
to decarbonize these things
we have a legally binding target now
some of this stuff will be difficult but
you know we have to go through the
journey we have to do it
the jobs market will be difficult enough
after the pandemic
the challenge is how to thrive in a
postcovid
green recovery lisa holland sky news
north yorkshire